according to the theories of human
social developments were now living
through the fourth great epoch of
technological advancements the
Information Age connectivity through
digital technology is a modern miracle
we can say it has broken down barriers
of time and space which separate people
and it's created a condition for an age
where information ideas can be shared
freely but are these great
accomplishments in digital technology
really the endgame in terms of what can
be achieved I don't think so and today
I'd like to share with you how I believe
digital technology can take us to even
greater heights I'm a surgeon by
profession and as I stand here today
talking to all of you five billion
people around the world lack access to
safe surgical care five billion people
that's 70% of the world's population who
according to the WHU shows Lancet
Commission can't even access simple
surgical procedures as and when they
need them let's zoom in on Sierra Leone
a country of six million people where a
recent study showed that there are only
ten qualified surgeons that's one
surgeon for every 600,000 people the
numbers are staggering and we don't even
need to look that far if we look around
us here in the US a recent study
reported that we need an extra hundred
thousand surgeons by 2030 to just keep
up with the demand for routine surgical
procedures at the rate that we're going
we won't be meeting those numbers as a
surgeon this is a global issue that
bothers me it bothers me a lot because
I've seen firsthand how lack of access
to safe and affordable healthcare can
bite the lives of ordinary people if
you're a patient that needs an operation
and there is an ax surgeon available you
left us some really difficult choices to
wait to travel or not to have an
operation at all
so what's the answer well part of you
are carrying some of that solution with
you today a smartphone a tablet a
computer because for me digital
communications technology has the power
to do so much more than just to allow us
to shop online to connect through social
media platforms and to stay up-to-date
it has the power to help us solve some
of the key issues that we face like lack
of access to vital surgical services and
today I'd like to share with you an
example of how I think we can make that
possible the history of surgeries filled
with breakthroughs and how science and
technology was able to help the surgeons
of the day face their greatest
challenges if we go back several hundred
years an understanding of microbiology
led to the development of antiseptic
techniques which played a big role in
making sure patients were able to stay
alive post-surgery
fast-forward a few hundred years and we
developed keyhole or arthroscopic
surgery which combines video technology
and precision instruments to make
surgery less invasive and more recently
a lot of you be aware of robotic surgery
and what robotics brings to surgery is
much like modern automated machinery
ultra precision the ability to carry out
procedures at the tiniest scales with a
degree of accuracy that even surpasses
the human hands but robotic surgery also
introduced something else to surgery the
idea that a surgeon doesn't actually
have to be standing at the patient's
bedside to deliver care that he could be
looking at a screen and instructing a
robot through a computer we call this
remote surgery it is incumbent on us to
find solutions that solve these answers
in a cost-effective and scalable way so
that everyone no matter where they are
in the world can have these problems
addressed so what if I told you that you
didn't really need a million-dollar
robot to provide remote surgery that all
you needed was a phone a tablet or a
computer an internet connection a
competent colleague on the ground and
one magic ingredient
an augmented reality collaboration
software using this augmented reality
collaboration software an expert surgeon
can now virtually transport himself into
any clinical setting simply by using his
phone or tablet or computer and he can
visually impractically interact in an
operation from start to finish
guiding and mentoring a local doctor
through the procedure step-by-step well
enough of me telling you about it I'd
now like to show you we're now gonna go
live to dr. Mark Tompkins an orthopedic
surgeon at the University of Minnesota
he's going to perform an arthroscopic
surgery for us the keyhole surgery of
the knee and I'd like to disclose that
this patient has consented to having
their operation streamed I'd also like
to point out that in the interest of
time we're just going to go through the
first steps marking up the patient and
just identifying a few key anatomical
landmarks hello dr. Thompkins can you
hear me everyone from Ted says hello all
right dr. Thompkins let's get started so
let's start with our incisions and where
we're gonna make these on either side of
the patellar tendon so if you can make
your incisions there and there that
should hopefully get us into the knee
[Music]
great so we're just getting inside the
joint now so why don't we go around and
have a quick look at the meniscus great
so we can see there's a small tear there
on the meniscus but otherwise it looks
alright and if you turn into this head
to this direction follow my finger let's
have a quick look at the ACL and the PCL
okay so that's your ACL there that looks
quite healthy no problems there so we've
just identified that small meniscus tear
there but otherwise the fluid around the
joint looks okay as well
all right thank you very much dr.
Thompkins thank you for your time I'll
let you continue have a good day bye
so I hope through this simple
demonstration I was able to illustrate
you just how powerful this technology
can be and I'd like to point out that I
wasn't using any special equipment it's
just my laptop and a really simple
webcam we're so used to using digital
technology to communicate through voice
and text and video but augmented reality
can do something so much deeper it
allows two people to virtually interact
in a way that mimics how they would
collaborate in person being able to show
someone what you want to do to
illustrate and demonstrate and gesture
it's so much more powerful than just
telling them and it can make for such a
great learning tool because we learn
better through direct experience so
house is making a difference around the
world well back in my teaching hospital
we've been using this to support local
district general hospitals and providing
skin cancer surgery and trauma
treatments now patients can access care
at a local level this reduces their
travel time improves their access and
saves money we've even started seeing
its use in wound care management with
nurses and in outpatient management most
recently and quite exciting it was used
in supporting a surgeon through a cancer
removal of a kidney and I'd like to
share with you a very quick video here
I apologize for some of the crucem views
if you see here that's the upper part
that most outer part of your tumor yes
so the 3 centimeter deep so this should
be 3 centimeters try to get a negative
margin anyway on the other side we
talked about to think of it a key we're
also seeing the use of this technology
at a global scale and one of the most
heartwarming stories I can recall is
from the town of Trujillo the north of
Lima and Peru where this technology was
used to support that the provision of
cleft lip and palate surgery to children
children from poor backgrounds who
didn't have access to health insurance
and in this town there was a hospital
with one surgeon working hard
provide this care dr. Surya now dr.
Surya was struggling under the sheer
demand of her local population as well
as the fact that she wasn't specifically
trained in this procedure and so with
the help of a charity we were able to
connect her with a cleft search in
California and using this technology was
able to guide her and her colleagues
through the procedures step by step
guiding them training them and teaching
them within a few months they were able
to perform 30% more operations with less
and less complications and now dr.
Saroyan her team can perform these
operations independently competently and
confidently and I remember one quote
from a mother who said this technology
gave my daughter her smile for me this
is the real power of this technology the
beauty but it breaks boundaries it
transcends all technological
difficulties it connects people it
democratizes access Wi-Fi mobile
technology are growing rapidly and they
should play a role in boosting surgical
provision we've even seen it used in the
conflict zones where there's
considerable risk in getting specialist
surgeons to certain locations in a world
where there are more mobile devices than
there are human beings it truly has a
global reach of course you still got a
long way before we can solve the problem
of getting surgery to five billion
people and unfortunately some people
still don't have access to Internet but
things are rapidly moving in the right
direction the potential for change is
there my team and I are growing our
global footprint and we're just starting
to see the potential of this technology
through digital technology through
simple everyday devices that we take for
granted to devices of the future we can
really do miraculous things thank you
[Applause]
[Music]